today on the matt walsh show the lgbt
cult is not satisfied to simply
indoctrinate everybody living on earth
today now they are setting out to
posthumously recruit the dead we'll talk
about that today also liz chady goes
down in flames and humiliates herself in
the process dr oz goes to the grocery
store and humiliates himself in the
process the irs trains agents to use
deadly force but based on the footage
from this training session i don't think
we have much to worry about in our daily
cancellation serena williams announces
her retirement and of course whines
about sexism on the way out the door all
of that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe is a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to rid our country of
abortion completely many companies are
bowing to the woke mob by donating to
pro-choice causes and candidates or
reimbursing their employees travel
expenses so that if they live and work
at a pro-life state they can travel to a
pro-abortion state and get an abortion
to be back at work on monday well what
if i told you that if you're currently
on a phone plan with one of the major
carriers you might be supporting these
companies and their pro-abortion agendas
with your monthly phone bill don't let
abortionists use your money to fund
policies you don't believe in switch to
charity mobile instead training mobile
is a pro-life pro-family cell phone
company that sends five percent of your
monthly plan price to the pro-life
charity of your choice you don't have to
compromise on values or good phone
service either charity mobile offers the
latest 5g phones no device or service
contracts great nationwide coverage and
live customer service base right here in
the usa the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes need your
support more now than ever you can help
by simply simply switching your phone
service to charity mobile today call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
wall street redeem a free cell phone
offer that's charitymobile.com and
mention code walsh
last week the globe theater in london
announced a new play called i joan about
the legendary 15th century saint joan of
arc but this play is not really about
joan of arc the actual historical person
who led a french army to major military
victories before being captured and
burned alive at the stake at the age of
19.
this play is about a fictionalized
non-binary version of the saint the
globe explained in an announcement on
twitter um
quote our new play i jones shows joan as
a legendary leader who uses the pronouns
they them we are not the first to
present joan in this way and we will not
be the last we can't wait to share this
production with everyone and discover
this cultural icon
so first of all shouldn't the play be
called we joan if it's they them
pronouns but of course grammatical
consistency is the least of the problems
that we have here uh accompanying the
announcement is a promotional image
showing joan of arc frail dirty sullen
and wearing a chest binder on their
website the globe continues its defense
of the portrayal claiming quote we are
not the first to present joan in this
way and we will not be the last
regarding the use of pronouns they to
refer to a singular person has been
traced by the oxford english dictionary
to as early as 1375 years before joan
was even born regardless theaters do not
deal with historical reality theaters
produce plays and in plays
anything can be possible
now it's true that they has often been
used uh through the centuries to refer
to a singular person that's true
but that's only when you're talking
about a singular person in the abstract
or hypothetically or
if you don't know the individual's sex
so for example
somebody cuts you off in traffic and all
you see is their back bumper and you
don't know who it is you might remark
that they are an a-hole or if you're
more dedicated like me you might speed
up so you can get a good look at the
person and then cuss them out with more
specificity but if you're speaking about
a specific known individual the pronoun
they makes no sense and serves no
intelligible purpose
there is no precedent in the english
language or any other language of using
they to refer to a specific man or a
specific woman instead of just saying he
him her
or her
and
there is certainly no precedent of
individuals selecting their own pronouns
for themselves and demanding that others
abide by that preference there is no
precedent for that that has never
existed anywhere in the world and it
certainly did not exist in medieval
france
now the theater takes refuge in the fact
that theatrical productions don't have
to deal strictly with historical reality
and yes there is indeed a long tradition
of events and people from history being
partially or totally fictionalized for
the sake of telling a story but in this
case they're fictionalizing joan of arc
in a way that completely negates nearly
everything that made joan of arc
significant to begin with the whole
point of the joan of arc story the
reason she's remembered by history and
has been revered down the centuries the
reason that she's a patron saint of
france the reason that she's beloved as
one of the great catholic saints is that
she did all that she did as a woman
to erase her womanhood is to erase her
this really isn't very much different
from reimagining frederick douglass or
martin luther king jr as white men
and something tells me that this theater
nor any other theater in the world would
be quite so
artistically open-minded as to host a
stage production depicting a black civil
rights leader as a white dude
you know the appetite to fictionalize
uh history these the appetite for
fictionalized retellings of historical
events
seems to be rather selective shall we
say
but the greater problem is that the
people pushing this stuff
aren't actually willing to admit that
their fictionalization is merely a
fictionalization
over the past few days various academics
and historians have come out of the
woodwork to try and vindicate the
queerified joan of arc the gay news site
pink news featured an article written by
alleged historian florence scott
claiming that quote gendering joan of
arc isn't that straightforward
she writes quote
joan is a particularly elusive and
complicated historical figure we cannot
possibly access joan's understanding of
her own gender or how she related to the
gender roles of her day we can only look
at the available source material and
interpret how she expressed herself
the picture is complex
gender as something that is constructed
evolves over time that means any role we
ascribe to a historical figure man woman
or non-binary is anachronistic muddied
by modern conceptions of gender that
doesn't mean we can't relate to jones
experience of gender just that there's a
whole spectrum of ways to relate women
have a right to be inspired by joan as a
strong woman acting in defiance of a
patriarchal society but those of us who
are queer or non-binary
should also be able to see ourselves
reflected in her transgression of gender
roles and refusal to conform in taking
such inspiration from medieval figures
we need to be aware we are placing our
modern experiences and values on someone
who didn't share them whether we
conceive of joan as a woman non-binary
or even trans masculine and i think all
three are valid historical readings we
must remember that we cannot define her
we can only interpret her
well actually no we we can define her we
can
define her in many ways okay define
means like if someone says who is joan
of arc or who was joan of arc we can
give an answer to that question we can
define her
we could say that she was born in france
we can say that she was martyred on may
30th 1431. we can say many objective
things about who she was and what she
did in between those dates we can say
that she was a human being and we can
say
that she was a woman
there is nothing complicated about any
of that
but as always the mo of the lgbt
propagandist
is to make murky even the clearest water
it is to create fog and confusion
wherever they find clarity
it is to unload a dump truck full of
meaningless jargon right into the middle
of every conversation
and it's also to rewrite not only our
current day reality
but history as well
and that effort to rewrite history is
now in full swing
over the last few days other academics
and historians have come out to argue
that joan of arc you know may not have
been non-binary but she was at least
non-binary adjacent or maybe she was
non-binary because this is how it goes
right first they first they say oh no
we're not claiming that
that uh joan of arc was actually
non-binary oh no actually we are
claiming that
how quickly we make that transition
and not satisfied to simply desecrate
joan of arc's memory by trying to
posthumously recruit her into the lgbt
cult they've now moved on to other
historical figures
because this is the other thing that we
know the left always does right they
always double down and so when they come
along and say where to portray joan of
arc is non-binary people are upset about
that their response isn't to back off
it's to say oh you know what
just because you're saying that not only
was was joan of arc non-binary but all
these other historical figures were too
the daily mail reports an academic
writing for the shakespeare's globe
theater has argued that queen elizabeth
the first may have been non-binary too
in an essay on the globe's website trans
awareness trainer dr kit hayaman
or i am
[Music]
that's not really what's important
what's important is trans awareness
trainer
is a job title
and this person referred to the virgin
queen with they them pronouns saying
elizabeth the first described themself
regularly in speeches as king queen and
prince
the essay was published on monday august
8th that was published in defense of the
portrayal and said that the common
portrayal of the story as pragmatic
gender non-conformity in a patriarchal
world denies historical existences of
trans experience
the leads based dr haim whose pronouns
are they them or he him compared queen
elizabeth first to 10th century english
ruler ethel fled lady of the mercians
who ruled murcia what is now
approximately the west midlands after
the death of her husband dr hayam said
ethelfled was later described as
conducting armies as if she had changed
her sex to take on a male-coded military
which was in some sense for ethel fled
to become male the writer and academic
says elizabeth first chose to
strategically emphasize their female
identity or their male
monarchical role at different points
now essentially what just to
clarify as much as we possibly can
what these academics are arguing is that
because these women of history
did things not traditionally associated
with women
or not traditionally expected of women
they must not have been women
as always the trans cult works to
rigidly and fanatically reinforce the
very gender binary that they pretend to
be breaking down
in their world it's
impossible that a woman might simply
elect to do masculine things
because if a woman does act in such a
way then she's a man
or at least she's non-binary
either way to sacrifice her femininity
even to the smallest degree is according
to trans activists to sacrifice her very
womanhood
now we can easily see
why they're so desperate to find
historical analogs for all of the gender
identities they've made up over the past
12 seconds
they're desperate because they claim
they didn't make any of this up
they claim that um
people are born trans born non-binary
that these identities are deeply
ingrained inside a person
and if that's their claim it becomes a
rather significant problem that these
deeply ingrained and inherent identities
never made an appearance anywhere on
earth for the whole history of the of
the human species up until just now
it's not just a problem
in fact history alone completely
delegitimizes their entire worldview
all of history testifies against them
their solution therefore is to retcon
their worldview back into history it's
to start draping rainbow flags over the
tombs of our ancestors
in some kind of perverse act of
ideological necrophilia they violate the
dead dragging them into their sexual
cult
their war on reality is not just
therefore happening in the present
it's also happening
all the more so in the past
now let's get to our five headlines
as international travel has picked up
this year so too has the appeal for
hackers to steal data from the travel
industry the marriott international
hotel group announced that 20 gigabytes
of sensitive data including guest credit
cards and information was stolen this
past june it's important to understand
how cyber crime identity theft are
affecting our lives your personal
information gets exposed so often that
it's dangerously easy for a cyber
criminal to steal your identity you can
protect your identity then and you can
do it easily with lifelock by norton
lifelock detects and alerts you to
potential identity threats that you may
not be able to spot on your own like
loans taken out in your name for example
if you do become a victim of identity
theft there's a dedicated us-based
restoration specialist that will work to
fix it for you nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses all the
time but it's easy to help protect
yourself today with lifelock identity
theft protection starts here join now
and save 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
percent off
start with a little bit of uh political
news liz cheney it's hard to even call
this news i think everyone was expecting
this liz cheney lost her uh primary race
by a large margin
i have the margin in front it was big
everyone saw this coming and we have a
we have her speech afterwards where she
well first she compared herself to
abraham lincoln
and then this i think is the clip where
she moves on to other
uh civil war figures
and continues this quite
humble comparison let's listen
in may of 1864
after years of war and a string of
reluctant union generals
ulysses s grant met general lee's forces
at the battle of the wilderness
in two days of heavy fighting the union
suffered over 17 000 casualties
at the end of that battle general grant
faced a choice
most assumed he would do what previous
union generals had done and retreat
on the evening of may 7th grant began to
move
as the fires of the battle still
smoldered grant road to the head of the
column he rode to the intersection a
brock road and orange plank road
and there
as the men of his army watched and
waited
instead of turning north back towards
washington and safety grant turned his
horse south toward richmond and the
heart of lee's army
refusing to retreat he pressed on to
victory
lincoln and grant and all who fought in
our nation's tragic civil war including
my own great great grandfathers
saved our union
their courage saved freedom
and if we listen closely they are
speaking to us down the generations
off we must not shut up liz uh
getting
um this is one of the reasons that she
lost by the way is that she is on top of
everything else just i could not think
of someone more
lacking in any kind of charisma
incredibly boring you know
um
and i think that that is actually is an
important point here because what now
now it's the question of well why did
why did she why did she lose and
the narrative on the left and even on
the right in some cases in many cases
really is that is that liz cheney lost
uh because she's a trump critic
and that's why she lost is that she was
going after trump and uh and now she's
gone because you can't attack trump with
the republican party
and again on the left like that's the
narrative that they want so they can
paint all
everybody on the right and all
conservatives they could say that well
the entire conservative movement is
really just about trump and if you say
anything about him then because one big
cult and if you say anything about him
then you're you're out
and there are some people on the right
who seem
to want to reinforce that perception
but i actually don't think that's true
now i can speak for myself
i personally don't
really care if a republican criticizes
trump or not
okay
that's not the litmus test for me
the litmus test for me when it comes to
a conservative a supposed alleged
conservative is not their opinion about
some other dude
and i don't care who the other dude is
everybody knows i'm a supporter of ron
desantis i hope that he runs in 2024 but
if there was a a conservative out there
who doesn't like rhonda sanderson there
are conservatives out there who don't
um i'm i'm not going to say well evict
them yes no you have to be on board with
ron desantis
i might not agree with the criticism of
the standards but that's not the litmus
test for me it's not it's not your
affinity or fealty to some other person
no matter who the person is
the issue with liz cheney is not merely
being a trump critic
the issue
is and the reason that she lost
is because she aligned herself
completely with the left and all of its
narratives
on on every subject including trump
now most prominently we know that she
was helping to lead this the the absurd
multiple charges towards impeachment and
everything else and we know everything
that she's done with uh with the january
6th theater
that's those are
that's that's part and parcel of liz
cheney's entire career
which is to align herself while calling
herself a conservative and republican to
align herself with the left
her voting record also speaks to that
and that is why she's out on her ass
deservedly so
because
we
she serves no purpose she's not
representing our interests
she's not even trying to
um
now the way that trump becomes a central
figure in that is that
and i don't think this is the case for
liz cheney i mean i think liz cheney has
never actually been a conservative at
any point
um
there have been other conservatives of
course who at least for a while
pretended to be a conservative and then
lost their minds because of trump
because they hate him so much
and have basically just despite him have
now adopted all of the left's talking
points on every subject
even talking points that they in some
cases spent their entire career trying
to
rebut and now just because of trump
they've
gone completely over to the other side
but that is the issue again it's not
just about criticizing trump it's about
are you
aligning yourself with the left's false
narratives or not or are you standing
against them
speaking of aligning with the left dr oz
is uh getting a lot of grief for
this video well we played the what i
think is the worst still thing it will
will endure is maybe the worst political
attack ad um
ever put out by a major campaign we
played that yesterday from from oz going
after fetterman
and this was a video from a few days
before that
and he's still getting a lot of grief
for this
this is his attempt i guess to relate to
the common man but uh
i don't know things didn't exactly work
out let's watch first
i thought it was a grocery shopping i'm
at wig nurse and uh my wife wants your
awareness vegetables
right so
here's a broccoli for what now it's two
bucks about a ton of broccoli there
there's some asparagus that's four
dollars yep
carrots i don't have a shopping cart
that's four more dollars there's ten
dollars of vegetables there and then
we need some guacamole that's just four
hours everything in their arms like that
okay and who buys yeah
must be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for kurute and this
doesn't include the tequila i mean
that's outrageous we got joe biden to
thank for this
i
okay first of all the salsa is expensive
because you're going for the expensive
salsa over in the produce section just
go over to the mexican food section with
the salsa that comes in the glass jars
and uh it'll be like half the price
and
i think actually tastes better than that
kind of salsa because that the salsa in
the produce section is always under
seasoned in my opinion and not nearly
spicy enough um and i i i guess i've
always known that there are freaks out
there who buy the store made
pre-packaged guacamole i don't know who
those freaks were but now we know like
dr oz is that guy you're in the produce
section go pick up a couple of avocados
you know how easy it is to make
guacamole and it's cheaper too you're
gonna spend six dollars on that little
like a little shot glass size of
guacamole go get a couple avocados and
some cilantro you should have you should
have most of the stuff already at your
house a couple limes and you're good to
go
now he's at he says he's at wegner's
which i
don't i you know this i i don't think
that's an actual grocery store i think
that he's so that's a combination of
what wegmans and another grocery store
and he's lo and he's trying to make what
is it crude crudite
i don't even know what crudite is
actually going to look like i don't know
how to spell it i want to look it up to
see what we're dealing with but crudite
okay here it is
assorted raw vegetables served
typically with a sauce
into which they may be dipped
so a vegetable platter
that's what normal people call it no one
calls it uh we're having some crudites
it's so you're having you're making a
vegetable platter
and you get a dip you're gonna dip it in
salt you you know dip what carrots and
salsa that doesn't even make any sense
you could tell
this guy
has never been he hasn't been to a
grocery store in like three decades
and he's so out of touch that this is
what he thinks people do he thinks that
people go to the produce section to make
crudite
you couldn't have chosen a more
like uh
common dish how about i want to go make
a salad so i'm in the grocery store to
make a salad
but
this is who we got in pennsylvania
that's your guy if you're republican
right supposedly
all right
nbc has this report it says boston's
children's hospital has warned employees
about mounting threats and is
coordinating with law enforcement after
far-right activists on social media
began targeting the hospital with false
claims about its treatment of young
transgender people it's the most recent
in a series of attempts to target
hospitals for their work with trans
youth adding to an ongoing wave of
anti-lgbtq sentiment that has hit
libraries schools and even a
trans-inclusive los angeles spa
the public relations office at boston
children's hospital sent an email to
employees with guidance on how to
respond to harassment and threats
earlier this week citing an increase of
threatening and aggressive phone calls
and emails sent to the hospital
commenting on treatment of transgender
patients
the email was confirmed nbc news by a
current employee
uh just a sidebar here always keep in
mind when they when they
when they claim that threats are coming
in that they're being threatened you can
never take that claim at face value
of course they're not above simply lying
and uh what's more we know what we know
what they consider a threat to be
right any any criticism is a threat
it is what was the word of the day that
we learned yesterday it is uh it is
scot
stokas stochastics terrorism is what it
is
so we already know that any any
criticism is an act of terrorism
and so when you hear um all of these uh
these news reports now lamenting the the
threats that are coming in against
boston children's hospital
always keep that in mind
that continues boston children's
hospital first became
the target of activists in recent weeks
when well-followed social media accounts
such as libs of tick tock
which is often promoted the groomers
discourse that falsely linked lgbtq
teachers and parents to pedophilia
began to make a variety of false claims
but we have to start there stop there
again
um first of all
the groomer the so-called groomers
discourse
links
teachers
and many other people on the left
to grooming specifically
okay it links them to conditioning and
sexualizing and grooming
so when we accuse someone of being a
groomer that's what we're accusing them
of
now as far as actual pedophilia
and the sexual abuse and rape of
children
well yeah there is a connection between
in fact a large number of teachers and
that and that's not a connection that
we're drawing or making up
that that's an actual epidemic in the
school system of the sexual abuse of of
children by school staff
the department of education did their
own report about it decades ago
and found that there are tens of
thousands of victims in the school
system
of sexual abuse by school staff and
teachers
that was back in what was that 2004
2005. do we think it's gotten better
since then do do these problems ever get
better on their own if they're not
addressed
if it is if it is revealed that there is
an epidemic of sexual abuse within an
institution
and there are not
serious far-reaching steps taken
to address the epidemic does it just go
away or does it continue to fester and
get worse i think we know
so but both of those things whether it's
teachers grooming their students and
bragging about it publicly or the actual
sexual abuse of students this is not
something libs of tick tock invented i
didn't invent it
this is just a fact
continuance has one allegation said that
the hospital offered gender affirming
hysterectomies to children under 18
years old conservative influencers with
millions of followers push similar false
talking points and fan the flames
further
and then it goes on the article goes on
quoting from the hospital
saying that this is this is a false this
is a false narrative it doesn't happen
here's a quote says in response to
commentary last week critical of our
gender multi-specialty service
boston children's hospital has been the
target of a large volume of hostile
internet activity phone calls and
harassing emails including threats of
violence towards our clinicians and
staff this was a ball of children's
hospital they just sent us out an email
we are deeply concerned by these attacks
on our clinicians and staff fueled by
misinformation and a lack of
understanding and a respect for our
transgender community boston children's
is proud to be home to the first
pediatric and adolescent transgender
health program in the united states
well as we talked about yesterday this
is
uh
nothing but obfuscation on their part
right they're they're homing in on this
one there were dozens of videos
that bosses children's hospital
published them themselves they put the
videos out there
and all that any conservative on social
media did was just
take the videos and say hey guys look at
these videos look at what they're saying
in the videos
only one of the videos
dealt with so-called gender affirming
hysterectomies
and but that's all they're responding to
because they feel safe there they can
say oh we don't we don't do that to we
we wait till you're 18 because that's
perfectly fine to do it an 18 year old
what they're ignoring and not addressing
is that almost all of these other
procedures they inflict on children
including top surgery double
mastectomies which um
are performed on girls all the way down
to the 12 and 13 across
across the country in many different
hospitals and clinics
but here's the point
uh
i'm again i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
accept on face value
that there are actual threats
you know that there's a that there's a
rash of actual like people saying we're
gonna blow up the hospital and that sort
of thing because that's when they say
threat that's what they want you to
imagine whether that's actually
happening or not
so putting that to the side the alleged
threats
what i do know that boss children's
hospital is receiving
is a a
an avalanche
of angry emails and calls
from people who are disgusted by what
they're doing to children
okay there are a lot of very angry
people
who are calling them out and calling
them to account and demanding that they
explain themselves and
you know
justify not that they possibly could
and that is exactly what should happen
okay the fact that boston children's
hospital is bragging about mutilating
and drugging kids and now has to face
this enormous nationwide backlash that's
not a sign
of uh that you know that we're
collapsing as a society the fact that
bost children's hospital is doing this
to kids that's the sign that we're
falling apart of the society
but people responding angrily to that
that's a sign of societal health
in a healthy society
it wouldn't just be boston children's
hospital that's the real problem here
it's not that boston children's hospital
is the target of anger
from us it's that
all these other hospitals
have so far gotten off scot-free
in a healthy society
when kids are being drugged and
mutilated
and uh
castrated and sterilized
the people that are doing this
are going to hear about it
and they're going to be the subject of
at a minimum um enormous anger from the
public
that's the way that it should be
and you know what if there's a there's a
real simple solution here's the good
news
if you're at boston children's hospital
or if you work at a gender affirming
clinic anywhere in the country
and you're worried
that people are going to start sending
you angry emails and calling you and
calling you out on social media and
everything else
here's the good news there's a real easy
solution
and that is a stop doing that to the
kids
stop hurting kids
and this problem for you goes away
stop hurting kids
it's the same thing for the for the
teachers who are bragging about sexually
indoctrinating their students
and now they're fretting and saying
well when when i brag about sexually
indoctrinating my students everyone's
mad at me what do i do this is terrible
i'm a victim
we'll stop sexually indoctrinating your
students
and you wouldn't have this issue
okay we we we are reacting in a normal
and healthy way to what you are
confessing
what you are admitting to doing so stop
doing that and this wouldn't be a
problem
uh moving on to this we know that
there's a fleet of new irs agents
coming down the pike here 87 000 to be
specific
and recently the job listing for these
new agents went viral with um
with some troubling details in fact the
irs is looking for apparently
agents who will carry a gun and use
deadly force
um if you so if you forgot to i don't
know claim your kid's lemonade stand
income last year or if you had a if you
had a garage sale if you had a yard sale
um and sold some uh old pairs of jeans
and like an old toaster and you didn't
claim it well
watch out because they're empowered to
use deadly force now this this uh
recruitment ad this job listing went
viral of course the media is running
cover
for them with some important context
here's marketwatch saying with the
headline yes the irs is hiring criminal
investigators empowered to use deadly
force but here's some important context
what is the context they say the
internal revenue services operations are
catching heat as the tax agency is in
line for an 80 billion budget boost
under the democrats proposed spending
plan and now there's intense attention
being focused on irs workers who
actually pack heat it started as
criticism from republican leaders that
the tax collecting agency would bring on
87 000 new employees to target regular
everyday americans quote unquote with
the 80 billion earmarked for the irs and
the inflation reduction act
reconciliation bill which looks poised
to become law but that's a misleading
claim according to the associated press
the bill passed in a 20 uh 200 220 207
vote of the house of representatives so
on and so forth what i'm looking for is
the where's the important context so
we've got a lot of information here and
a lot of claims
but we're supposed to be getting
important context that makes it less
terrifying
that they're recruiting irs agents to
use deadly force against americans so
i'm skimming through
okay
uh here we go
it says though the job is really about
sniffing out so this is the irs criminal
investigation division
though the job is really about sniffing
out income and accounting irregularities
to build legal cases
one of the potential duties is
conducting or participating in
surveillance armed escorts dignitary
protection undercover operations
execution of search and arrest warrants
seizures etc there are 300 vacancies for
that role which pays between 50 000 and
about 90 000 annually according to the
list
though the job listing drew new
attention this week requiring some irs
agents to potentially use deadly force
is nothing new an irs criminal
investigation spokeswoman confirmed
okay
i'm glad we could finally get to that so
that is the missing context that's the
important information that we need
that makes this all better it's like no
no the irs they've been shooting and
killing people for a long time this this
is not new we've already been doing this
so everything's fine
oh okay well i guess that makes it okay
no actually it is still terrifying
until
here's the encouraging part
um
depending on how you look at it maybe
this is encouraging
representative thomas massey published
some photos
that he found from the irs's recruitment
class
and this is these are the people that
they're bringing in and recruiting to be
in their criminal investigation division
and these are the people are going to be
equipped to use deadly force so we've
got the tweet here
and you can look at
do we have the individual photos you can
you can you can look at okay let's okay
stop right there for a second
so
here we go first of all all right
where to begin
and what what am i allowed to say here
without getting banned
that's the real question
uh
so these are the people that they're
equipping with deadly force
these are going to be the irs
warriors so we've got um four women and
an individual in a wheelchair
and apparently
and the you know the individual
wheelchair he is he's he's having a
great time and that's fine because
having fun is the most important thing
they tell you at the irs that's the
first thing they tell you
is the most important thing is to have
fun while you're shooting
delinquent taxpayers
and apparently they're training the irs
agents to shoot people in the back
so he's pointing the gun right at
somebody's back whose hands are behind
his back
and then you've got the other uh women
in the back who are just kind of
standing around and i guess they figure
well hey this is already taken care of
we're going to take this guy out
that's what you get
for discrepancies on your w-2
and then but the more concerning
pictures and that can we go to the next
picture
dear god
uh
again it's a question of where do we
even begin
we've got
this is kind of a fun game here to go
through and like point out all of the
gun safety violations that you can find
in this picture
not very good trigger discipline my main
problem is with the the girl right up
front there the way that she's holding
the firearm now i don't claim to be an
expert you know i'm a firearm i'm a gun
owner myself and i have taken some
classes but i don't claim to be an
expert on this and yet i look at that
and immediately i think well that is not
proper form for holding a fire that is
how you hold
like a cup of hot cocoa that's how you
hold a venti latte at uh
at starbucks that's not how you hold a
gun
because you're still go here's what's
going to happen she's going to fire if
that was a real gun
and she's pointing it at somebody's back
because they didn't claim something on
their taxes she's going to fire it and
then the recoil especially because this
is a small kind of frail woman you know
she's gonna fire the recoil it's gonna
go right back into her face
that's what's gonna happen
and then you've got charlie's angels in
the back there she's holding the gun up
she's ready to go
and then you've got the woman all the
way in the back
and the on the back of the the wall
there she appears to be pointing the gun
at the woman in front who's holding the
gun the wrong way
is that the penalty for bad form when
holding a firearm is that you just get
shot on the spot at the irs
so maybe this is the good news
and then we have one more
well these are obviously physically fit
i mean these are warriors right here
so maybe this is the here's the good
news maybe
that if the irs comes to your house
they're going to end up shooting each
other before they can shoot you
not good news for your carpet and your
furniture and all the cleanup you're
gonna have to do but
i don't think you have to worry about
these people exactly
all right let's get to our comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
andre says matt on the work from home
issue i want to raise you two points you
haven't brought up one work from home
enables city dwellers like myself with
tech jobs to finally move out of the
move out and to the countryside
and two homeschooling even for kids that
attend public slash private schools
investing the time you would otherwise
spend on a commute into your children
i see that benefit outweighing the cons
well i agree with you on both counts
that's what i was saying yesterday about
the work from home issue again as
someone who did work from home for years
there are definitely
potentially benefits for it but all of
the benefits really come from the the
free time you know because in a typical
office environment you are you are
potentially wasting a lot of time uh and
that's not just the commute but all the
pointless meetings and everything and in
a lot of offices there are
there are people that are like
constantly looking to justify their jobs
and so they're calling meetings that
aren't necessary and they're just
wasting everyone's time and yeah to be
able to avoid that and yet still do your
job i can see the benefit and then
you're freeing up all that extra time
but then it becomes a question of what
what are you using the extra time for
and i think
the unfortunate reality
is that for so many of us whether we
work from home or not
because of modern luxuries and
conveniences we we have we can free up a
lot of time but then we end up just
giving that time back to the very
technology
that freed it up for us
so that's that's the thing about the
technology the technology is
self-interested right it's very selfish
it's like it doesn't want to help you
just for you it wants to help you so
that you have more time to give to it
and i think that's uh that becomes a
problem
all right
another comment says one thing i liked
about working from home during the
coveted lockdown is that i could listen
to sweet daddy walsh ruthlessly cancel
people and throw down truth bombs during
the work day it's tortured have to wait
till after work hours during the drive
from up that is a good point that is and
i should have mentioned that now that is
obviously the number one advantage from
working from home that does cancel out
all the other potential negatives is
that you can listen to the show whenever
you want
um
jillian says
i've been a long time viewer and matt
walsh is my favorite commentator i am
child free and i'm aware that it's a
minority in conservative groups the
biggest reason that we don't want to
take the term childless is because those
who are child free usually haven't had
miscarriages the term childless refers
to those who have tried and haven't been
able to carry the term or have a
stillborn the usage of child free is not
malicious we just don't want to take the
word childless because we made a
conscious decision to not have children
and the term childless should belong to
those who wanted them and grieve that
they haven't been able to it's not
malicious intent child free folks also
do not hate children at least the
majority of us don't and we just we just
don't want any of our own also most
child free are that way due to financial
reasons i'm a big advocate for making
sure you're in a stable place before
forcing someone into existence they baby
shouldn't be relied on to fix all of
your problems and marriage etc they're a
huge huge commitment beyond infancy and
so many don't even see that they just
think i want a cute baby and don't think
about how much work goes into it it's a
life commitment okay um
i obviously agree with you that it's a
it's a lifelong commitment
you say that the child free community is
not anti-child or is doesn't hate
children
i that i believe that that's the case
for you but
you know just go to any so-called child
free forum and the thing is i i can't
spend a lot of time on those more but i
haven't looked at them before
and that's like all you see
is just people who despise kids and
really do see them as a disease
i understand your distinction between
childless and child free
but
that's the reason why most people use
the term child free is because
uh they want to look at it as a pause i
am free of the burden of children that's
what it means right i'm i'm child free
i think the the the fact that it has a
similar ring to a similar ring to
cancer-free is not a coincidence
and also just
once again the fact that
you know if you don't end up having kids
for whatever reason
you know that's that's one thing that's
always happened in history there's
always been people who don't end up
having children of course
but when it becomes part of your
identity i'm not saying that's the case
for you
but the very fact that there is
something called the child free
community and they have forums and they
have you know
like you're you're defining yourself by
your lack of
something
that i think is the most troubling thing
uh
let's see evan says
i'm a pretentious effect former academic
so i can tell you that some of the
jargon these people use in the academic
sense stochastic literally means
something that may or may not happen
no seriously that's what it means it
doesn't even mean that something is
statistically probable it just means
that it's possible
that's actually a really important point
too because when i originally heard this
term stochastic terrorism the first
thing that i did was i i admit i never
heard the term stochastic before it it
just had never come across it that would
have ever used it in my presence and so
i looked up stochastic and that's what i
found it said stochastic actually means
as you say
according to the dictionary something
that's random just like it could happen
maybe it won't but maybe it won't
yet stochastic terrorism
means
that you're demonizing someone
leading to
potentially uh violence
and so that's where the yeah the term
stochastic is actually important
because what they're saying is that if
you say something
that could
or could not
compel someone to violence
then you're terrorist
but obviously by design here
well then
that means that like everyone's a
terrorist
because it's it's possible it's
theoretically possible that anything you
say at all could drive some maniac to go
do something
it's theoretically possible
and so they give themselves the
framework to just paint assaults
terrorists which obviously is the point
are you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
and see masculinity is toxic and think
that you should teach your daughter to
shave her beard well there is a better
way jeremy's razors are 100 real and 100
woke free the premium matte tungsten
handle has more heft than the left the
razor head pivots without caving and has
six blades that are sharper than truth
those other razor companies keep virtue
signaling to the totalitarian left and
using your money to do it at the same
time but you don't have to let them when
you buy jeremy's razors you aren't just
making jeremy richer you're making the
woke left poorer which is even more
important 75 000 people have already
made the switch you can too visit
ihateharrys.com to get your founders
series shave kit today that's i hate
harrys.com jeremy's razors shut up and
shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
recently serena williams retired from
tennis and for most athletes you know
after a long and
successful career
retirement is a time for bittersweet
reflection it's a time for uh gratitude
but gratitude has never quite been the
serena williams way i suppose neither
has maturity nor dignity nor likability
and so serena staying true to form
is riding into the sunset with her 260
million net worth and whining the whole
way out in fact she says that her
retirement is not prompted by her age
but by sexism
cnbc reports tennis legend serena
williams has been a fierce advocate for
gender equality both on and off the
court and when she announced her
retirement from the sport tuesday
morning she made an important point
about the unique sacrifices women must
make in their careers in a vogue article
williams who turns 41 next month said
that she will retire after the us open
which begins in late august
the winning tournament would tie her
with margaret court's record of 24 grand
slam titles quote i have never liked the
word retirement williams wrote in the
article which was transcribed from her
conversation with vogue contributor rob
haskell maybe the best word to describe
what i'm up to is evolution i'm here to
tell you that i'm evolving away from
tennis toward other things that are
important to me
okay well so far so good right that's
that's all that's all fine i guess
almost i mean the whole uh
i'm not retiring i'm evolving bit it's
pretty annoying and pretentious but i'm
willing to overlook it and actually i
looked up the full quote serena williams
actually said that um
she would describe herself as in the
middle of a transition but she doesn't
want to use that word because she
doesn't want to appropriate it from
trans people
that's what she said but we're going to
let that go because we have other
problems to deal with the article
continues
williams cited her family as the main
reason why she'll step away from the
sport writing that her four-year-old
daughter olympia wants to be a big
sister williams has been married to
reddit founder alexis ohanian since uh
2017 the desire to expand her family
however wouldn't be a career-ending move
if she were a man williams points out
believe me i never wanted to have to
choose between tennis and a family she
wrote i don't think it's fair if i were
a guy i wouldn't be writing this because
i'd be out there playing and winning
while my wife was doing the physical
labor of expanding our family maybe i'd
be more of a tom brady if i had that
opportunity
okay
so there's the problem
and
it's difficult to know
exactly how to respond to that because
it's so crushingly stupid and incoherent
it's it's also self-contradictory as she
was just worried about being sensitive
to trans people and now here she is
making the transform transphobic claim
that men don't have babies and that's
very problematic
but that aside
it's not clear
what her complaint is exactly
like she whines that men don't have to
do the physical labor of expanding the
family but what does that mean
is is she referring to the fact
that women are more likely to be the
primary caretakers of children
well that can't be it because she has
hundreds of millions of dollars and
certainly already has an army of nannies
and various other servants on standby
she's not home every day raising her
current four-year-old daughter she's
obviously made arrangements there so why
couldn't she do the same thing for the
next child
when you've got 200 million dollars in
the bank uh there's there's no reason
why if you don't want it to the reason
why having a kid would stop you from
doing anything you want to do
if you have no problem with having a
nanny raise them
or is she
when she says physical labor is she
actually referring to the labor of labor
is she talking about the fact that women
are the ones who physically bear and
deliver children
well we could only assume that that's
what she meant and if so her complaint
is less petty and selfish than it is
just insane
i mean it's not fair that women are the
ones who give birth what
who what do you mean not fair who are
you registering this complaint with
exactly
nature god
or do you imagine that human
reproduction is a patriarchal conspiracy
as if sinister white men in smoky rooms
conspired to set things up this way
calling a woman's role in human
reproduction unfair
is like saying it's unfair that uh birds
can fly and we can't or it's unfair that
gumdrops don't fall from the sky when it
rains
it's unfair that there isn't actually a
pot of gold at the end of a rainbow
unfair thing is a thing that happens
outside
of the rules or not in accordance with
the principles of justice that's what's
unfair so what rule
what principle of justice is violated by
the nature of human reproduction
any claim of unfairness is an appeal to
some higher authority or principle so
again who or what is being appealed to
here
to top it all off serena is bitterly
complaining about a pregnancy that
hasn't happened yet she's gonna try to
get pregnant potentially having to use
medical assistance given her age and and
yet she's complaining the whole way as
if the thing she's planning to do in the
future and says she wants to do is
nonetheless gonna happen against her
will it makes no sense
well that's not exactly true
i can make some sense of this
serena williams
like any sufficiently modern and
progressive western person
hates herself
and she rejects herself
see
the way she sees it is that
her femaleness
is somehow apart from her true self
right like there's there's her herself
there's her and then there's there's her
femaleness and her femaleness intrudes
on her true self
causing inconveniences and interfering
with her tennis career
she does not see herself as a completely
integrated whole
and that's because nobody on the left
does
they divide themselves into pieces and
put aspects of themselves at war with
other aspects of themselves
they become bitter and sullen feeling
somehow persecuted by nature itself
though they can't explain how and they
don't know who to complain to about it
and the great shame in serena's case and
in the case of so many leftist women
is that is that
while she's doing all this complaining
you know she's failing to see the
blessing
she sees as a curse what is really a
blessing
a woman's ability to conceive to harbor
and bring forth new life onto the earth
is a beautiful
miraculous gift
and you know what it's something far
more significant and important
than swinging a tennis racket around
so it's not just that she's complaining
and whining about it
why do i have to be the one to give
birth
well that's one way of looking at it i
guess
but the healthier way of looking at it
the way that has more gratitude and will
make you a happier person that also
makes a lot more sense
is to say i get to be the one
you know i have been blessed with this
enormous gift and also power
that men don't have
but as we already discussed gratitude
is unfortunately far outside the reach
of
people like serena williams and that is
why she is today
on the cusp of her retirement
cancelled
and we will not leave it there for today
we in fact will go now to our next
segment our members only segment
and if you are not a member then go to
dailywire.com become a member and we'll
see you over there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you